[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka
guten Abend schaut man sich Europas
Wetterkarte in diesen Tagen an und hört
Klimaforschern zu die sagen dass das
künftig noch viel heftiger werden wird
dann kann man sich schon fragen ob man
irgendwann überhaupt noch sagen wird in
den Sommerferien fahren wir in den Süden
vielleicht fährt man dann lieber zur
Erfrischung in den Norden so wie das
arabische Touristen hier heute schon tun
wer sich dort leisten kann sitzt lieber
im Englischen Garten in München als in
der Wüstenhitze von Dubai wobei im
Englischen Garten wird es ja auch immer
heißer
im Juli die Akropolis in Athen zu
besichtigen zu besichtigen das war
dieses Jahr jedenfalls keine gute Idee
über die Hitzewelle in Südeuropa
Christian Kirsch
Urlaub das fühlt sich eigentlich anders
an heute Vormittag vor der Akropolis in
der Hitze Athens kollabierende Touristen
das Rote Kreuz verteilte zehntausende
Wasserflaschen wir sind hier um
denjenigen zu helfen die trotz dieser
Hitze unsere archäologischen Städten
besuchen wollen
bei fast 40 Grad ist die Akropolis ab
sofort von 12 bis 17 Uhr geschlossen es
ist einfach zu heiß
dass wir so stark vom Tourismus abhängig
sind ist auf der einen Seite sehr schön
wir streben das an als Land auf der
anderen Seite ist der Tourismus sehr
anfällig für die Auswirkungen des
Klimawandels das Phänomen schreitet sehr
schnell voran und deswegen hätten wir
uns schon längst anpassen müssen um
dieses Produkt den Tourismus zu schützen
griechische Meteorologen messen und
staunen Hitzewellen sind hier nicht neu
aber häufiger jetzt wächst die
Waldbrandgefahr
ich würde sagen die schwierigsten Tage
liegen jetzt vor uns ab dem Höhepunkt
dieser Hitzewelle und danach wenn wir
erwarten in den nächsten Zeit auch eine
Verstärkung der Winde über der EG ist
diese Bedingungen fördern leider die
Ausbreitung von Waldbränden sehr
ganz Europa erlebt eine massive
Hitzewelle oft mit Temperaturen nahe an
und über 40 Grad wie hier in Rom
hier sollen die Temperaturen weiter
steigen auf 43 Grad am Dienstag im Süden
Italiens drohen gar 48 Grad Celsius
wir sind in einem alarmmodus wir haben
auch schon alle Freiwilligen Feuerwehren
kontaktiert damit Sie Ausschau halten
nach Feuer
extreme Hitze der Sommer eher bedrohlich
als entspannend
der fortschreitende Klimawandel stellt
reiseroutinen in Frage bedroht
vermeintlich solide Geschäftsmodelle im
Sommer in den Süden
die Gefahr dass die Touristen zukünftig
in andere Länder fahren die ein besseres
Klima als Griechenland haben das muss
unser Land begreifen um mit allen
Beteiligten am Tourismus dazu einen Plan
zu entwickeln und den muss es jetzt
entwickeln
eine der intensivsten Hitzewellen aller
Zeiten befürchtet Italiens Wetterdienst
die Flucht ans mittelme hilft da nur
wenig Wassertemperatur derzeit rund 25
Grad steigend
die akute Sommerhitze ist das eine nicht
weniger gravierend sind die Folgen der
andauernden Dürre schon im Winter gab es
wieder nicht genug Regen und Schnee
nicht genug um die Grundwasserspeicher
überall ausreichend zu füllen das ist
längst auch in Teilen Deutschlands ein
Problem in den besonders betroffenen
Regionen müssen Kommunen den
Wasserverbrauch beschränken
Wassermangel herrscht auch in den Alpen
es fehlt an Schmelzwasser Quellen
versägen darauf muss ich auch der
Bergtourismus einstellen berichtet
Claudia Vogelmann
am Watzmann wird das Wasser knapp waren
die Felsen vor wenigen Jahren selbst dem
Hochsommer noch von riesigen
Schneefeldern bedeckt sieht es nun so
aus lange Trockenperioden wenig Regen
kommen in diesem Sommer noch hinzu wer
ist bis hierher geschafft hat hatte eine
lange Wanderung hinter sich das
Wasserhaus ist eine wichtige Schutzhütte
in den Berchtesgadener Alpen vor wenigen
Jahren wurde das Haus renoviert auf
Komfort wurde dabei bewusst verzichtet
so die Hütten so sind keine Duschen
eingebaut worden
und das Wasser ist sehr stark gedrosselt
wer hier übernachtet darf keinen Luxus
erwarten Duschen sucht man vergeblich
aus dem Hahn kommt nur wenig Wasser die
meisten Wanderer haben dafür Verständnis
vollkommen in Ordnung Katzenwäsche
reicht aus zu Hause hat mir jeden Tag
eine frische Dusche in der warmes Wasser
alles in Ordnung in Zisternen wird das
Schmelzen Regenwasser gesammelt sind sie
voll reicht das Wasser für 30 Tage
Hüttenbetrieb mehr nicht bei langen
Trockenphasen wird es eng es ist etwas
was vielen vielen alten daran töten in
den letzten Jahren schon Schwierigkeiten
gemacht hat und dieses Jahr deutet sich
auch an das einige Hütten
die den Betrieb mal einschränken müssen
oder komplett einstellen müssen bei
Ihnen dieses Jahr wieder das Wasser
finden wird das Watzmannhaus ist ein
wichtiger Stützpunkt für Wanderer und
Bergretter Thomas Gesell Sie die Lösung
weiter unten bei der Kühe rein einem
Training Stützpunkt der Bundespolizei
bis dahin könnten Wasser Abwasser und
Stromleitungen entlang der Forststraße
verlegt werden davon soll die
Schutzhütte profitieren
von dort auf mehrjährigen die Zimmer
hier zur Hütte rauf also das ist nur
kurze Stück im Wald der Rest würde dann
hier im freien Gelände liegen Wasser
aber auch Abwasser und Stromleitungen
sollen quer durch den Nationalpark über
die Felsen zum Watzmannhaus verlegt
werden der Bund Naturschutz hat klagen
angekündigt es handelt sich um die
Kernzone des einzigen alten
Nationalparks und es müssen
naturschutzfachlich sehr hochwertige
Flächen durchschnitten werden und das
lehnen wir ab die alpenversorgen viele
Menschen im Tal mit Trinkwasser nun muss
das Wasser wieder dorthin gebracht
werden wo es zu schnell versickert und
verdunstet am Ende werden nur die
Gerichte entscheiden ob das Watzmannhaus
Wasser aus dem Tal bekommt oder nicht
man hört im Moment ja nicht sehr viel
von den Kampfhandlungen in der Ukraine
die Offensive der Ukrainer kommen nur
langsam voran heißt es wie sollte es
auch schneller gehen ohne Lufthoheit
Präsident silensky dämpft zu hohe
Erwartungen jeder Kilometer sei ein
Erfolg und das gibt Erfolge in den
letzten fünf Wochen haben die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte nach
Einschätzung von US-Experten ein
Großteil des turns befreit das Russland
zuvor in mehr als sechs Monaten erobert
hatte der Preis dafür ist brutal Kriegs
Invaliden junge Männer mit Amputationen
gehören inzwischen zum Stadtbild Dara
Hasan
als ob michen keine Grenzen der Name des
Kiefer
Rehabilitationszentrums gibt die
Richtung vor
Russland ist im März auf eine russische
Miene gedrehten jetzt kämpft er sich in
ein Leben mit Prothese
auf der psychologischen Seite da
versuchte ich die ganze Zeit über
positiv zu bleiben nach der Explosion
sah ich dass ich kein Bein mehr habe es
ist kein Grund darüber in Panik zu
geraten so versuchte ich positiv zu
bleiben mit Humor Stück für Stück
Lebensmut ist das eine eine passende
Prothese die andere Grundlage für den
Behandlungserfolg die Prothesen werden
in Handarbeit direkt in der Werkstatt
des Zentrums gefertigt individuell
abgestimmt auf die Form des Stumpfes
sehr oft helfen uns Prothesen den
Phantomschmerz zu bekämpfen wenn die
Spiegeltherapie oder andere Behandlungen
nicht wirken dann hilft es wenn die
Patienten sehen dass sie eine Prothese
haben sie verstehen es und der
Phantomschmerzen nimmt ab
70% der Patienten sind inzwischen
Soldaten und es werden mehr vor dem
russischen Angriffskrieg versorgten sie
hier zwei Patienten die Woche jetzt sind
es 30
das Zentrum arbeitet an der
Kapazitätsgrenze
heute ist mein erster Besuch heute habe
ich meine ersten Schritte gemacht
ich fühle mich gut
Roman hat beide Beine verloren auf zwei
Prothesen laufen zu lernen ist noch
schwieriger seine Frau begleitet ihn
er lag für Monate im Bett und als er
dann im Rollstuhl saß war das schon ein
großer Fortschritt und jetzt wenn ich
ihn in Sportschuhen sehe aufrecht
stehend es macht mich einfach so
glücklich
draußen dagegen gibt es manchmal noch
Unbehagen noch spüre man zu häufig
starrende Blicke und Unsicherheit im
Umgang sagen sie hier nicht nur
Angehörige und Patienten müssen lernen
ein Leben mit Prothesen anzunehmen auch
die ukrainische Gesellschaft
wir bleiben noch einen Moment in der
Ukraine für das Land gab es heute ein
weiteres Zeichen internationaler
Unterstützung Südkorea ist Präsident
kyol kam nach Kiew zu Gesprächen mit
Präsident selenski nun sagte die
Lieferung von weiteren Militärgerät zu
sowie Ausrüstung zur Minenräumung und
humanitäre Hilfe es war uns erster
Besuch in Kiew
der Vorschlag von SPD-Chef klingenball
das Ehegattensplitting bei der Steuer
für neue ihn abzuschaffen sorgt weiter
für Diskussionen von FDP-Chef von
Finanzminister Lindner kam mit dem
Verweis auf Mehrbelastungen für Paare
Widerspruch er sagte br24 das wäre der
nicht kommen in dieser Wahlperiode es
sei weder in der Koalition verabredet
noch für die Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler fair
in Italien waren Flugreisende heute mit
einem Streik beim Bodenpersonal
konfrontiert und 1000 Flugverbindungen
und etwa 250.000 Passagiere sind von dem
Ausstand betroffen schätzt der ein
italienischer Verbraucherschutzverband
bei mehreren Fluggesellschaften legten
auch Piloten die Arbeit nieder
in Windeln sah man heute gleich zwei
Tennisspielerinnen die nach dem
Matchball mit den Nerven ziemlich am
Ende waren die eine weil sie unverhofft
dass Turnier gewonnen hat und das kaum
fassen konnte die andere weil sie ihr
großes Ziel endlich einen Grand Slam
Titel zu gewinnen nicht erreicht hat die
Nerven wie gesagt die waren mit dem
Spiel der Druck war dann wohl doch zu
hoch
dieses Wimbledon Märchen einer erstmals
ungesetzten Siegerin rührt auch
Landsfrau und tennis-ikone Martina
Navratilova denn die favorisierte
vorjahresfinalistin or jabeur im
Hintergrund schöpft nur im zweiten Satz
einmal kurz Hoffnung als sie nach 0 40
noch zum eins zu eins ausgleicht doch
die Tunesierin auf die ganz Afrika
blickt kann ihre Nervosität nicht
verdrängen kassiert erneut zwei Breaks
Makita wondruschova nach nur einer
Stunde 20 Minuten mit dem zweiten
Matchball zum Sex zu vier sechs vier
ich denke es ist die schmerzhafteste
Niederlage meiner Karriere
wunderschön ist bis zu diesem Finale nur
42 der Weltrangliste letztes Jahr
Zuschauerin nach einer schweren
Handverletzung
ich hatte zu dieser Zeit letztes Jahr
einen Gips das ist erstaunlich heute
hier zu stehen tennis ist verrückt
das Happy End gefeiert mit Ehemann und
Schwester
und du hast jetzt noch mehr Sport1
Schwimmsport bei den Weltmeisterschaften
im japanischen Fukuoka gab es gleich im
ersten Wettbewerb eine Goldmedaille für
das deutsche Team Leonie Beck gewann den
freiwasserwettbewerb über 10 km kurz vor
dem Ziel setzte sie sich ab und schlug
mit gut 4 Sekunden Vorsprung an aber sie
Zeit zwei Stunden zwei Minuten 34
Sekunden
und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr sechs acht elf 17 30 39 Superzahl
1 und weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie
auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf
Seite 556
und jetzt noch die Wetter Aussichten am
Sonntagmorgen ziehen die heftigen
Gewitter dieser Nacht rasch ab im
Bereich der Donau und südlich davon muss
aber weiterhin mit einzelnen Gewittern
gerechnet werden Schauer gibt es auch
ganz im Norden sonst bleibt es mit einem
Mix aus zahlreichen Wolken und Sonne
meist trocken bei einem lebhaften an der
Nordsee auch stürmischen Südwest sind
werden 21 bis 30 Grad erreicht die
weiteren Aussichten auch in den nächsten
Tagen kann es ganz im Norden und an den
Alpen gewittrige Schauer geben sonst ist
es oft freundlich und trocken bei 20 bis
32 Grad
ja zu enden wir wie wir begonnen haben
mit Hitze und damit können wir dann
wahrscheinlich morgen gleich
weitermachen bis dahin auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]